As we go to our next game,
the Midnight Spoil:
Batman v Superman.
Well...
it's on the horizon.
After a mere 33 years of teasers
and trailers and press tours
of Batman and Superman staring
at each other
from various angles
at uncomfortably close range,
Batman v Superman: Dawn of...
They're doing it there!
Finally comes out today!
Who will win?
Will it be the bat man?
Will it be a superman?
A tired entertainment industry
built on franchise power.
I could tell you,
but I don't want to spoil it.
So instead
I'll let the comedians do that
with our first installment
of the Midnight Spoil!
Comedians, please give me
as many spoilers
from Batman v Superman
as you can.
And if you tweet at me
that we're giving away
actual spoilers, (bleep) you.
I'm gonna put 60 seconds...
They're not... these are
not real. Don't get upset.
Don't yell at me on reddit.
Uh, I'm gonna put 60 seconds
on the clock. And begin.
Jess.
No matter how good or bad it is,
-you won't like it.
-Points.
Alison.
Robin Thicke plays Robin.
Points. Nicole.
They (bleep).
Points.
Finally. Jess.
(laughter)
Uh... Penguin is in it,
but it is a real penguin.
All right, points. Alison.
Batman's suit has tiny little
kryptonite nipples.
Nicole.
Wonder Woman finds out bukkake
is not a villain.
Points. Nicole.
Um, the whole movie is
just one big long Grindr date.
Yeah, points. Points.
(gruffly):
I, uh...
I-I couldn't help but notice
you were in my area.